this album man super personal album i
feel like um
you know you got some records on here
that are crazy you got
two nipsy features on this project that
are
like very special records i feel like
the lebron james record with dom kennedy
is a
is a banger yeah and i feel like the
other one is
one of the better knit verses i've heard
in a long time man like
he got off on that [ __ ] yeah now do you
now
now go ahead go ahead no no go ahead i
was gonna say like what what is the
process of
like how many unreleased nip records do
you have
obviously your home team so i'm assuming
that you you uh you you have some
you know i know you know dave east uh
who's on your project a couple times as
well right
he's you know he's got some [ __ ] with
him that no one's heard but like
see see now that last you know what i'm
saying that second song you heard you
feel me that was like an
energy that we was in the studio and had
did like
cuz went crazy and then i went crazy
right
but the verse that i use is not is not
even
diverse you feel i'm saying bro was like
he said [ __ ] everything you said on
there was the money he said just change
the first four bars he said he changed
the first four bars
he said the rest of that [ __ ] is money
so
instead of changing the four bars i just
changed the whole verse and just went
crazy
yeah you smell you spat yo cause nip
kicked that thing off man
on fire yeah but we held on to her for a
cold minute right right right right
right right
you know what i'm saying we didn't do
[ __ ] to it so after a while
just started getting outdated i revamped
the beat and i'm like man this [ __ ]
perfect for the album
yeah because i know that nipsey was like
very uh
like he had an intent when he recorded
it wasn't like nipsey wasn't the kind of
guy who would like
you know do 150 songs and like you know
you know there's those artists that like
quantity over quality sometimes right
but i feel like nip everything he did
was like very
um specific it had purpose it was like
you know like
so so in your in your estimation like
how much
nipsey versus records
that are you know on hard drive
somewhere that we haven't heard yet
hey man a lot it's so much music this
[ __ ] didn't did bro like
you you you wouldn't even imagine bro
it's [ __ ] that i haven't even heard
when i thought i heard everything from
saying like is there a
have you heard any i like like plans
obviously pop smoke passed and we got a
his a crazy album from him after he
after he died and i think
that you know a lot of nipsy fans are
like i wonder if we're gonna get one
more nipsy project
and i know it's not going to be as
cohesive because you know he's not here
to
if if it were to happen he's not here
it's going to take a lot of production
it's going to take a lot of you know
is that something that's been been
discussed it's going to definitely
be another nip album you know i'm saying
but you know you got to take time with
that though my money in so you know we
ain't going to
put out nothing mickey or do it just
exactly what i'm saying you guys feel
like
like you know what i'm saying wrestling
piece of pot
i feel like if they would have held on
to his music a little bit
more you know what i'm saying and put it
out the right way
it would have been received different
but the music was still good and we
needed it at that time so you know
yeah they definitely um after after park
died
i feel like they didn't take their time
with
putting together those projects as much
as they probably could have yeah
and nip had his brand and his image so
so so strong and tight like
you can't you know what i'm saying you
can't do the pack on them with the
machiavelli one machine really 15.
remember all those cds yeah
i remember just hearing about all those
yeah and then when napster came out i
was downloading all the [ __ ]
tupac bootlegs off the [ __ ] internet
man right yo that's crazy
yeah cause i i do think there is
something to be said about
like with poc like there was like some
of those
post death albums that were solid but
some of them just felt like they just
kind of
kind of threw [ __ ] together and it was
like can't do [ __ ] together when they
could have waited and then there was the
one album that had like features with
people he probably never would like
everybody even did a song bro like why
is tupac doing a song with trick daddy
and
and all like and g-united [ __ ] like bro
like
you don't even know these cats you know
what i'm saying like and i feel like
with with nip it's got to be very
you got to take your time if that
project happens
everything's got to be super you know i
mean the same way he took his time with
victory lap
yeah and it was a perfect album for sure
in the same way you know what i'm saying
so that'd be crazy though if we hear
that man
um yeah that'd be crazy i don't know i
really can't say but i just
well you did say earlier
but listen man shout out to nip i hope i
hope we hear
uh because you know some of these verses
that have been coming out deep reverence
with sean was crazy
uh the the you know the stuff on your
albums like
there's been some the the uh obviously
the khalid record was special yeah i'm
glad that they that they got to release
that video
yeah yeah never got a chance to pull up
on khaled
at his crib you know what i'm saying
they vibed out and knocked that [ __ ] out
there